[Musique]
à nous pas loupé à l'eau pas de bol
visiteurs t on au libor
bonsoir les enfants notre nounours est
très gai ce soir je descends jouer
patron et ce soir c'est moi qui ai
préparé une surprise à l'intention de
mes amis amuse-toi bien mais ne fait pas
trop le fou mon école et hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
beaucoup
saluent les enfants
[Musique]
sur les partis
il a oublié ses souliers on vient de les
retrouver allons ne soyez pas triste il
reviendra à votre ami cornichons
vous voyez mais j'ai une belle surprise
pour vous si jani khel
une jolie histoire que je vais vous
raconter
voilà mon histoire se passe dans les
pays bas pourquoi les pays bas n'ont ce
qu'est ce que ça
les piles bras c'est un pays où la mer
est plus haute que la terre
[Musique]
mais les habitants ont construit de
grande digue qui empêche la mer d'entrer
dans les terres
les hollandais ils sont très courageux
écouter la suite de l'histoire
il ya très longtemps
j'ai eu une tempête terrible tout près
de la digue il y avait une jolie petite
maison dans laquelle vivait à papa une
maman et leur tt ça qui sait le fleuve
qui se jette dans la mer il y avait non
une très grosse trentaine et le vent se
fait très très fort il jetait les vab
contre l'as dit
buck le bébé dedans même tranquillement
et seul le chat de la mer vous avec
apple les parents ils étaient 7
un moment de faire ses commissions et le
papa à son travail et tout à coup
la mer grâce elle a dit qu il est grand
d'énormes 20 litres est dans le fleuve
il s'était dit bon d'asthme
le fleuve ou paddle
tatras trop quelle catastrophe le long
de moi le vent ne souffle plus la
tempête avaient cessé mais la jolie
petite maison avait disparu
mais à la surface de l'eau quelque chose
bougeait c'était un chat qui se trouvait
sur un perso emploi qui se balançaient
au gré des rares et ligny le chat
l'avait sauvé car ils avaient peur de
l'eau tous les chats et à chaque fois
qu'une vague allaient pénétrer dans le
berceau ils sont 1 de l'autre côté pour
ne pas se faire mouiller
ils ne se rendaient compte de rien car
ils dorment le chérubin lara ils
cherchaient leurs enfants avec une
barque ils étaient treize un pieu coup
tout coup il y arrive bien ça mais oui
vite ils se sont approchés ils ont
retrouvé laurent ans qui dorment
toujours
[Musique]
les hollandais ont reconstruit leurs
digues encore plus solide
u les parents leur maison encore plus
jolie qu'avant la trempe heures ça ils
l'ont beaucoup gratter et le bébé a
grandi en sa compagnie et on a faim son
meilleur ami elle était très jolie cette
histoire merci une annonce
voilà pas trop paru
nous allons nous coucher tout seul bonne
nuit bonne nuit les petits
[Musique]
où
oui
[Musique]
cornichons est reparti avec ses parents
mais il reviendra bientôt voir nicolas
et pimprenelle il reviendra patron il
reviendra à rod nounours ben et nuit
fait pour eux
[Musique]